Kelly
[Applause]
I guess I just wanted to say I knew you
were starting today and I was just not I
wasn't in the neighborhood I came here
just to say congratulations good luck
and I want you to have a really great
show
[Applause]
is that a chair yes I was looking I was
looking for the exit and they said it
was that way and I and I'm so I'm
interrupting your show and I'm so sorry
you're here they love you I love you
actually I'm so glad you said that I
actually brought a gift so for for my
first show Jennifer Aniston she's a
friend
she dropped she brought me a gift for my
first show and it was good luck because
cuz I'm on for 17 seasons and I want the
same for you nope so she brought me a
welcome mat and it was good luck and I
wanted to bring you something for your
set so that you had okay I gotta get
from Ellen
[Applause]
first of all your childlike hands this
is going in my office no no it's
supposed to be on the set don't you
threaten me with a good time ma'am
all right I'm gonna find the perfect
spot maybe just like on the brick wall
maybe we do that but we all talk about I
want to be a part of the conversation
okay well we were talking about
Instagram ease have you ever heard of
that I just recently did when I was
backstage waiting to come back out well
yeah well wait wait where's baddy baddy
'he's not theirs baddie hey daddy
[Music]
[Applause]
she's from Kentucky and has nearly 4
million viewers
okay wait so daddy your real name is
Helen so you do you like to go by Helen
or buddy
well I like to be called baddie because
everybody mostly knows me I love your
body and I am a baddie [ __ ]
[Applause]
always been a rebel I always will be a
rebel
yeah you said bitching how did you get
started on Instagram I'm curious cuz my
mom's not on screen okay yeah I took one
little picture so it went viral in a
week
oh that's cute well how do you how do
you keep saying so young is it staying
on Instagram is that your secret oh well
I I get on Instagram almost every single
day
takes time do you have any advice for
other crannies out there wanting to nail
it on Instagram the lighting in the
ankles is lighting a thing I had to
learn that yes but if they want to be on
Instagram just get on there do your
thing and be yourself my god I love you
before I go I want to wanted to ask you
because I brought you a gift
yeah if you had a gift for your audience
because that's they like I like gifts I
don't know if you heard Ellen but I did
give a gift of song
we're first season here hello tiny
budget we have a budget-- Bedouin well I
brought something for the audience I
don't want to stand here can we bring in
the easel out or sorry an easel hey why
don't get an easel you have a budget
ferny I have a budget all right I just
want this to stay like me the whole show
that would be amazing
yeah there's no stays there the whole
season the whole seriously do you have
any advice for me come on okay I said
have a seat I know I'm used to that too
yeah so you're enjoying it I am yeah
you're not bored with it yet no okay no
but I love it yeah it's a fun it's a fun
thing because you have the proximity of
the people right here and they get the
energy and they get to see you so
close-up I had to move him forward
because even on tour I don't like when
the audience is so far I like I play off
of them I agree you're probably like
that you're commuting obviously so yes I
like people close up and I like how lit
they are because they're part of the
show there it's not like it's you
[Applause]
yeah so everyone's lit with little
things so nice of you know but obviously
you said you had a gift so I'm just
gonna bring it up against I'm excited
[Applause]
that's a you know people like gifts that
you have a gift and now I wanted to give
something to the audience very kind oh
this is this is exciting I think you're
gonna like it
who likes kittens all right now I'm just
curious it's just a question there's
nothing to do with the gift I just love
kittens all right
who likes plants ficus plants like
houseplants ferns I the succulents are
so easy to take care of really have to I
don't have to do anything it's a cold
person's plan yeah
it's someone who doesn't really have to
have responsibility at all yes all right
so no succulents see there are no plant
nope nope okay no I'm just playing
around wasting time I love and I can't
you can waste my time in a hole hello I
can't I have to actually get back to my
show I came over here to see you to give
you this but I have to now do my show as
well but so the gift is you all know
that for I don't know like five years
now maybe more we've been in business
with TCL Roku and they have the best TVs
and so everyone here needs to have a 65
inch TCL
[Applause]
we really want to know what the box look
like that it came in as well I don't
know why we didn't just bring out the
really nice to do it's gonna look like
on our doorstep I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this